so can I just ask what brought you down
here you know the same
dissatisfaction with politics in America
bring back our jobs from China this is
being billed as a neo 60s revival of
protest and performance and it's not you
know this is a legitimate contemporary
socio-economic disaster we're in right
now
you know the people here are responding
to it the recent decision to allow
abundant donations is something that's
completely unacceptable
I think making all college education
wonderful and great but then you also
have to take if you can't well how are
we gonna find these universities and
then you have to look into tax dollars I
strongly believe that we should give
ourselves away from the monetary system
and probably work for a resource-based
economy get back somehow in a way where
we could barter you have to convince the
central government that they have to
empower the power that the banks have
and take them home but for that that's
why we're here to convince people so you
think the central government should take
over the banks absolutely say there was
a Republican administration would you
still trust the government to run the
bank's Republican no no not really
who's controlling the information here
that's just it since there's no leaders
there's no
and it's the spin nothing have you been
down here from the start no I came up I
got here Wednesday morning at what I am
I've read that some of the demands are
starting to get a little more specific
and one of them was universal
mrs. takes discussing with him that this
discuss fearless movement when I just
got a full rank
some of that would make you a leader of
this particular part of motor are you I
didn't work right now Sam where's the
local one plump lemons house I used to
get $200 a week for 40 hours a week
man 11 has been the pretext for
systematic dismantling of our
Constitution and Bill of Rights the
Obama's administration is reading from
the same playbook as the Bush's
administration I think it needs to be
Wall Street report but we also have to
remember that one third of the city's
revenue comes from Wall Street right now
okay one third of the city's revenue
stream already comes from Wellesley I am
disgusted with the thought of giving any
form of of subsidy to a bank to to a
corporate entity it is it is despicable
to take money from the citizens for a
private use
I'm also against eminent domain so I'm
being constitutionally consistent when I
say that I'm not a supporter of Barack
Obama we murdered they pulled the
trigger on a American I find to be
dangerous it sets a bad precedent and
Ron Paul recognized it as well
don't think that it's just going to be
American Muslims that are gonna get the
bullet you know there'll be Christian
Christian Americans will get the bullet
as well I voted for Obama personally I
really don't
nothing enough
and if he was they look very bad had and
and he's hamstrung and all the
politicians who they are hamstrung so
many of them are just not really even
able to act on their own colleges
because they're at the mercy of these
interest groups because of the way that
our electoral system is right so your
approve choice your abortion rights
group and you are not permitted to have
political speech sixty days before an
election how is how does that movement
get hurt
was it the Internet would you vote for
Obama again Republican candidates are
just too scary would be irresponsible
not to but I do want to express my
dissatisfaction with Obama and that's
why I'm here today not completely
Democratic but for like a socialist
democratic the combination claim is the
one that took us off to glass-steagall
Mike in 1990s he's the one to Democrat
but Democrat that said that allowed the
bankers to do what they did and that's
exactly what they did
I like Mitt Romney I believe Mitt
Romney's gonna do the right thing you
know this is actually an ongoing process
smaller events and I'll wrap up into a
movement and success is measured by the
fact that there is actual discussion
about financial industry issues
I still believe you know in the
principles of America and the
Constitution and in capitalism as well
you know you win you lose now when these
corporations these people when they lose
they should just lose this is like you
know this is I mean it sucks
all right great you know when I lose
nobody comes helps me